[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR ISLAM: All right,
so what we're calling this,
the enabling
conditions hypothesis.
I did send you an op
ed that was published,
I think, about two
years ago in a newspaper
in Bangladesh called "Neither
necessary nor sufficient."
So this is what the idea was.
"Neither necessary
not sufficient-- three
enabling conditions for
effective transboundary water
management."
So I started with this idea
that does life cause death?
Does oxygen cause fire?
Does rain cause flood?
What it means,
essentially, then,
if you look at these
three questions going
from very philosophical point
of view, that life cause death,
of course, you need
life before you can die.
Just because if you are
not alive, you cannot die,
but does it cause it?
The same thing with
oxygen. Will oxygen--
does it cause fire?
Why is this important?
Because right now, I'm
sitting in my room.
I have oxygen, but
there's no fire.
But think about the situation
really about maybe 5,000 years
ago, when we did not
know about all of this,
and we had a lot of fire
in many different places.
Then you are a scientifically
minded individual,
you went and measure
everywhere, and you
find that, in every place there
is a fire, there is oxygen.
So then you have a theory now.
That theory tells you
oxygen cause fire.
It's a good theory because I
don't think-- basically, think
about it 5,000 years ago.
I did not know any
of this chemistry.
I did not know oxygen.
But I found out
certain things are present
in all situations when
there is fire.
So now, I am basically
very brilliant.
I came up with the theory--
oxygen cause fire.
So this is the fundamental
problem of cause and effect,
or observing certain things by
observing certain other things
and trying to link them.
So what I argue that this
is really fundamentally
what scientific
methods are all about.
You take observations, then
you formulate a hypothesis,
and then you test it,
and then you refine it.
So now, if you are
5,000 years ago,
then how do you know that
oxygen is not causing the fire?
What do you have to do?
This is where this idea of
necessary sufficient conditions
become extremely problematic.
In this particular case, now
you know that, for example,
in my room right now, I'm
sitting here, there is oxygen,
but there's no fire.
So that means, why
it's not there?
[INAUDIBLE] is necessary,
but not sufficient.
What is sufficient, then?
You need to have some trigger.
If you have a trigger,
then it will start fires.
We will now start basically--
put some fire here, maybe
with a candle or
something that makes
my house may get into fire.
So there's the distinction
we need to make,
but this is, right now,
may seem very obvious.
But when you get
into the messiness
of the transboundary
water management
or other complex
problems, there are many,
many causes can
create an outcome.
Many, many causes can create
something that you see.
So fire is what you see.
Then you try to
attribute some cause,
and then you get into this idea
of necessary and sufficient
conditions.
What we are arguing
really, in complexity,
that no, in complexity,
problems are the problems
which are complex, where many,
many variables and actors
and institutions are
interacting with each other.
You simply cannot isolate
cause and effect very cleanly.
There are causes, of
course, but those are not
easily identifiable.
As a result, you
get into trouble.
What happens, really?
You may identify
something as cause,
then very quickly you find
out that is not the case.
And you are seeing this with
COVID-19 over the last 14
months.
We have attributed
to many, many things
there's a causal
conditions, then
later on, we found
out they may not be.
And we even found out that
all kinds of solutions,
starting from using
bleach from our president,
but these are all
essentially just trying
to relate some
arbitrarily linked things.
And in the simplest
case, people would
say that there are
some correlation maybe.
And you know the correlation
is not causation, but that's--
we said this is very cliche.
We're not interested.
We are fundamentally challenging
this idea of cause and effect,
that you simply cannot identify
cause and effect very cleanly
as you can in some other cases.
Even in the simplest case,
does rain cause flood?
And one of us said, yes.
Yes, it does.
In most cases, it does, but
in many cases, it do not.
So think of, really,
in Boston, it
was not raining for
the last several days.
Now, if it rains
one inch, there'll
be no flood because
most of the water
will essentially infiltrate
and go to the ground.
Now, if it rains for three
days in a row, yes, basically,
soil will get saturated.
You'll get flood.
So that means you
need some conditions.
So here, rain is a
necessary condition,
but it's not a
sufficient condition.
The problem of this
type of analysis
really came if you go back now.
Where is this idea of
necessary and sufficient came?
So I did dig basically
deeper into this.
It came from geometry.
In geometry, it is
very precise because I
need to have four sides
to have a rectangle,
and with 90 degree angle.
I need to have three
sides to have a triangle.
There is no way around it.
So I can explicitly
say, what are
the necessary and sufficient
conditions for something
to be considered a triangle?
That is not the case for
many physical systems.
More importantly,
many coupled systems,
like where you have natural
systems and human systems,
like our transboundary
water problem, where
you have natural
systems, so water
is getting coupled with the
human systems of managing
it and governing it.
When they're coupled, the
systems become complex.
This notion of necessary
and sufficient conditions
are not good enough.
So I'll stop here just
to give you pause.
See what you think
about this distinction
between necessary
sufficient conditions.
Then we'll go into
enabling conditions.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
I presume we don't
have to wait 5,000 years to make
judgments about such things,
and I'm interested
in how you think
we know enough to say that's
only correlation, that's
not causation.
And is it really--
could it be a function of time
and perspective and experience,
and that there's not really a
method to know that quickly?
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Yes,
we'll get into something.
Basically, I did
not have a chance
to discuss this with you.
So we are basically
making distinctions now
between two types of facts, and
this is part of the discussion
that we have today.
So one thing that,
over time, that we
have learned this idea
of scientific method
and scientific facts.
Another thing that
basically we are [INAUDIBLE]
has been used in social
science for quite some time
called social facts.
And we are making a sharper
distinction between these two
right now, so what I argue
really in this particular case,
that scientific
facts are basically
a particular type of facts.
Those facts are verifiable,
reproducible, replicable.
Those will not depend on
daily perspective or notion.
They may depend on
matters over time,
but there is a way
to get around this.
That's the whole idea
of scientific method,
so we'll talk about that.
Social fact, on the other
hand, does not have to be true.
Does not even have
to be verifiable.
It's just, we believe.
It's just that we
accept it as reality.
And that is fine, too, and
we have done many of these.
For example, this whole idea
of currency is a social fact.
We give tremendous
amount of value
now to this something
green called dollar,
and whether I'm in Bangladesh
or in Boston doesn't matter.
Everybody accepts it.
Whether they believe in
me, whether I am a atheist
or I'm agnostic or I am
Muslim does not matter.
You accept it that
this is something
that everybody thinks is good.
And now, think about
what is happening
with the Iranian currency.
It has been
significantly devalued
because of all this embargo
that we have created.
So that is really a
paper, and that paper
has certain value because
everybody in the world
thinks the dollar
is very valuable.
This is social fact,
and there is no way
to justify whether
this is true or not.
It is true right now.
I can use it anywhere
I want, but I do not
know what will happen to this
really 10 years from now.
So those are the
distinctions we need to make,
and we will make those
distinctions when
we are talking about scientific
fact and social fact.
In this particular
case of your fire
can be basically determined
by scientific method
because what can we do really?
Even 5,000 years, we
didn't have to go that far.
We can find out really that,
although oxygen is necessary,
it does not create
fire everywhere.
So that means something
else has to happen,
so that is a systematic
way of doing experiments
and then to find that out.
But I have seen few places where
there is fire there is oxygen,
so my immediate conclusion could
be that oxygen causes fire.
Then there has to be question,
and we find over time.
So let's go with this enabling.
So what we are
saying here, that we
need three enabling
conditions, and I
was careful not to use this
idea of necessary and sufficient
anymore.
So three enabling
conditions are needed
for any boundary crossing
complex water agreement
to be initiated,
implemented, and sustained.
So this is a very big
claim we're making here.
So whether you are working
with the Indus treaty
or you are working with Ganges,
what we are saying then,
Mashroof, if you want to be
basically writing your Ganges
treaty for 2026, yeah,
we want to do it.
We need to be very careful
about these three conditions.
You may say no, no, I
need something else.
Then we'll talk about this.
But what I am saying that, at
least these three are needed.
So what are these three?
The first one is there has
to be an active recognition
of interdependencies,
meaning that if you need
to sign a Ganges treaty
between India and Bangladesh,
they have to actively
recognize interdependencies.
India has to recognize
that Bangladesh exists,
and they need them.
Just saying that because
India is upstream,
Bangladesh is downstream.
Of course, there is already
interdependency there,
but that's not good enough.
What is happening right
now, if you think about it,
like Animesh, and we worked on
a little bit with Brahmaputra,
Brahmaputra is creating
serious problems
between China and India, but
there is no active recognition
right now.
China, India, although
they're independent,
is saying that you
are using our water,
and we are in serious trouble.
But they have never, so far,
actively recognized this.
As a result, really,
what we argued that, no,
I don't think they're
going to go to any treaty.
And they are not right
now, although there
is a lot of noise,
a lot of discussion,
a lot of international
forum, international funding
agency trying to find out what
is going on in Brahmaputra.
What I'm arguing that I'm
yet to see anything that
is tangible happening
in the Brahmaputra,
so if you have to ask me, these
are dangerous game to play.
In terms of prediction,
there would not
be a Brahmaputra treaty signed
unless this recognition is
active between China
and India, and that
is exactly what happened really
if you look at Indus Water
Treaty.
Indus Water Treaty was signed in
1960 between Pakistan and India
because they actively recognized
that this is important.
About the same time,
President Johnson from the US
sent another envoy to
Israel and Palistine
to have Jordan treaty.
Jordan treaty was not
signed until 1994.
So why one was signed in
1969, another was in 1994?
In both cases, US was
basically a significant player.
So you need to think
about those treaty.
Then I say, yeah, look, at that
time, they did not recognize.
Jordan did not recognize Israel
is important or vice versa.
So as a result, it
took a long time.
In 1994, they came,
and basically, they
signed the peace treaty.
Part of that was a
water treaty, too.
So you just think about
those two cases between Indus
and Jordan, then you
get some clue really
what this enabling
condition 1 means.
Second one is that, I'm sure
you've talked about this,
mutual value creation.
So just because you've
recognized the problem,
and you have a conflict,
is not good enough.
Now, you have to
see, really, can you
create some mutual value
through negotiation
that both parties will benefit?
Because otherwise, you have
limited amount of water,
and you have no
way to divide this.
And your actual
need is much more
than what is actually
available, then
how do you get around this?
So only way then you
can get around this,
if you create some
mutual value, and then
you can do it many
different ways,
I'm sure Larry and Animesh
has given you ideas of,
really, how to
create mutual values.
How do you connect
different type
of sectors and different
resources, and so on?
You don't have to
talk about water only.
You can bring in food.
You can bring in energy.
You can bring in security.
You can bring in military power.
All kinds of things can be done.
DR. GAIN: So to
discuss these things,
if we consider this
Ganges example,
we already had the Ganges
treaty, but in my view,
this mutual value creation
didn't happen until now.
But already the treaty
has been signed.
So what do you say about that?
Although this enabling
condition didn't meet,
but there is a treaty
or negotiation?
PROFESSOR ISLAM:
Notice the EC here,
we said the initiative
implemented and sustained.
DR. GAIN: Yeah.
PROFESSOR ISLAM:: So
yes, you can have it
because you have it for--
basically, all the mutual
value fully was not done,
but it was done partly.
There were certain things done.
For example, Bangladesh
could have told India
that, look, if we want
to have this treaty now,
you want transit,
we'll give you transit.
So India wanted transit
really from, basically,
to go through
Bangladesh to Tripura.
See, they want to do
this, said let's do this.
The Bangladesh trying to
do this Ganges barrage now,
so for Ganges barrage, India
may get flooded a little bit.
Can that be brought
into the picture?
So the issue is
that basically you
have to bring in other issues.
Those are now basically
being discussed in Bangladesh
right now.
If you think about what
is the particular problem
with the Ganges, Ganges is not
a problem for the flood season.
The problem is really
the dry season.
See, in the dry
season, the flow goes
down so low that we have serious
issues of water shortage.
So take a hypothetical example--
if you take the entire
water, basically
during the dry season, it's
about 4,000 [INAUDIBLE]..
Still, it would not be good
enough to keep the Kolkata port
navigable.
One of the primary reasons
that India wanted to build
the Farakka barrage was to
keep Kolkata port navigable,
but in the dry season, the flow
goes so low, it still cannot--
even they have
taken all the water.
So that means they have to come
up with alternative sources.
Can they use ground water?
Can this basically store
water during the flood season
over extended
period of the river?
That is what Bangladesh
proposed in the Ganges barrage.
So this is a over 50
mile river that will
be using as a storage device.
Because Bangladesh is
a very flat country,
we cannot create another dam.
So that's another
mutual value creation
option can be explored.
AUDIENCE: Let me ask you
a question, professor.
PROFESSOR: Please.
AUDIENCE: So you said
something very interesting,
that creating mutual values.
From what I understood--
I might be wrong--
that anything goes.
So one of the tension
between Bangladesh and India
is Bangladesh being
used as a vessel
to create trouble in
its Seven Sisters, which
is why it is of India's
interest to maintain
the security in Bangladesh.
So I'm wondering if that sort
of value can be created even--
I mean, can this be used
as a bargaining chip?
So that is what I want to know.
PROFESSOR: Definitely, yes.
I'll tell you
something that is--
I think you hit
it exactly right.
So about three years ago, when
we have our water diplomacy
workshop, and
Larry may remember,
we have four individuals
from Bangladesh
foreign ministry came
from foreign ministry
really to learn about water
diplomacy in our workshop.
And their primary
concern was that they
want to work on the water
treaty, what would they do?
So we discuss the
Seven Sisters issue,
and we discussed that this is
an issue that, yeah, this is
a security problem for India.
Can that be used,
that Bangladesh
will create
opportunity for that,
so that these insurgencies do
not create problem for India?
Yes, this is open
for discussion.
You can link that
with basically water.
AUDIENCE: In that
case, so I can actually
bring security where
I work [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Yes, you can.
You can-- and then definitely,
and this is a relevant problem
for India to basically keep
taking care of those Seven
Sisters and this insurgency
is a serious security problem.
And Bangladesh can help.
And also, Bangladesh can
be used as a transit.
But then, Bangladesh has to
ask something else in return.
That is why the
discussion must go on.
This is a discussion I had
with the foreign minister.
And even after that,
so I went to Bangladesh
and we did have a workshop
on water diplomacy
within the Foreign,
basically, Ministry.
And then pandemic started.
Of course, then we got stuck.
The difficulty,
I'll tell you, this
is just not to be shared
with Bangladesh government.
So I think the difficulty
that we have in Bangladesh--
many of these ministries are
extremely, I think I would say,
progressive.
But there is no system memory.
Meaning that water secretary
is water secretary right now.
Suddenly, he gets transferred
to transportation.
That memory doesn't
exist, that basically he
needs to do certain things.
And that does not continue
to the next secretary.
So as a result, really, you
reinvent everything every time.
And that's a problem.
AUDIENCE: And then the lack of
institutional memory is like,
it's a serious issue
in developing countries
like Bangladesh.
I completely agree.
I work for the government
so I understand.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: So that's
a different problem.
So that's the way
we'll go later, maybe.
So the third one
that we're seeing,
this adaptive regime
of governance.
And that is also very important
because you need to anticipate.
I think, Hossain, you are saying
that, yes, in industry there
is no climate change dimension.
Because in 1960, we did not
know even climate existed,
let alone climate change.
So we have no idea about this.
So but, they did not
put any provision.
But they did put some
other provision though.
If you look at the industry,
they had a technical provision
that they said that if there
is a technical problem,
that Pakistan and
India cannot resolve,
somebody else should
come into the picture.
You know what that
somebody else was?
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: I
have mentioned it already.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Oh, you did?
OK.
All right, so that
was brilliant.
That was brilliant.
The question is
basically, why there
might be precedent has to be
basically somebody has to come
in and then appoint a body.
Because they thought MIT is
a good technical institution.
They may still exist for
50, 60 years from now.
And they will have no interest
in India and Pakistan.
So this was brilliant.
So when you are trying
to design this treaty
for Indus or for
the Ganges, you need
to be also thinking forward.
Basically, you don't
know what will happen,
whether climate
change will come.
What will happen if another
COVID-22 comes in, who knows?
But there has to
be some provisions
so that this can be used.
What we are doing
in this enabling
condition hypothesis is this--
if they are not in
place, your treaty
is not going to be
basically implemented well.
It cannot be
sustained very well.
That's a big claim.
So I want to hear or
maybe you can do it
later as well that, find out
a treaty that was initiated,
implemented, and sustained
for a long period of time.
But one of these
conditions were missing.
That would be a good exercise.
I could not find one yet.
But are these going
to guarantee success?
No.
They're not going to
guarantee success.
But you can see, these
are minimum subset.
The one example I usually
give to make it simpler
is that if you want
to get a PhD, what
are the enabling conditions.
Number 1 is obvious, I think,
that you have to be alive.
Otherwise, you cannot do it.
So fine.
Number 2 is that you need
to have a bachelor's.
Unless you are getting
an honorary degree--
we're not talking
about honorary degree.
If you said earn PhD, you
need to have a bachelor's.
So which bachelor's,
I do not know.
It could be in
political science.
It could be in hydrology,
could be in computer science.
Does not matter.
But you need to have a
bachelor's, at least.
Everything else are situational.
You need to have an advisor.
You need to have funding.
You need to have a topic.
All kinds of things
will be needed.
And then, of course, you have
to pass the qualifying exam.
A department has
different requirements.
You have to take this
course, that course.
Those are called
situational conditions.
If first two enabling
conditions are not there,
you're not getting.
But just because you
have those first two
doesn't mean that
you'll get PhD.
No.
So that's what
the difference is.
So when you're
thinking about this,
you're thinking
along those lines.
So these are not necessary
and sufficient conditions.
I'm not telling you what
will be necessary to get
a PhD, what will be
sufficient to get a PhD.
But I'm just telling
you that you need
these two enabling conditions.
Then, you need many, many
situational conditions.
And those situational conditions
are context dependent.
It will depend whether it is at
MIT or Tufts or somewhere else,
whether you're in engineering
versus in urban planning.
They have different
requirements.
DR. GAIN: But then,
what is the difference
between a necessary condition
and enabling condition?
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Oh no,
necessary conditions
could be many.
I'm telling you that you don't
need more than these three.
I can come up with many
necessary conditions
that may not still satisfy all.
And see, the reason
I think I want
to get away from this
necessary and sufficient,
as we mentioned, this really
came from a very structured
discipline called geometry.
So I'm trying to solve
a geometric problem.
Now I want to apply it to
my messy transboundary water
management problem.
That's the reason I want
to make the distinction.
Because here, if you look at
the news and look at writings,
you'll see that, yeah, this
was not a necessary condition.
We did not satisfy
necessary conditions.
Then you ask them, OK, so what
are the necessary conditions.
So to give you a
simple example, I
tell you that I want to
go from here to New York.
So what are the necessary
and sufficient conditions?
Can you exhaustively write this?
AUDIENCE: No, there
would be thousands.
So it is not possible
to cover them all.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: You got it.
So this is basically
a very large space.
I may decide to walk.
I may decide to take a plane.
I'll take a bike.
I'll take a bike and
then I will take a boat.
Or I have a donkey.
So I essentially cannot
exhaustively write down all
the conditions.
That's what the difficulty is.
So that brings us
to something else
that I want to start
maybe our talk.
So let's start there.
AUDIENCE: Legal language
sometimes like try to, I mean,
make conditions
that are exhaustive.
For example, if the
corporate of a chocolate
is asked by a
lawyer, then he would
write that this chocolate has
to be from this particular tree.
And it cannot be consumed by
any other party without paying
the money to the original
company in any form.
So in this way, they
can probably minimize--
I don't know whether I
could make sense or not.
But the legal language
sometimes tries
to cover all those
conditions that you say,
that there are so
many conditions.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Sure.
So this is where
essentially now I
think you got it exactly right.
So this is what
basically-- although we
don't want to talk about
our previous procedures.
So now if you come into
the problem, really,
if you want to define really
what the presidency should
entail, does president have
to really file taxes and make
it clear.
This was not explicit.
It was not explicitly he has to
file taxes and make it public.
So he decided not to do it.
Now the question is,
how many things can you
write down explicitly
the president has to do.
Then I have to even tell you,
when he goes to the bathroom,
this is what he has to
use just to make it--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR ISLAM: So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR ISLAM: The problem is,
so this is exactly the point.
So for the presidents
of the United States,
how many things you can
explicitly write what
he or she does really
as a president.
We cannot do this.
So we are assuming
that certain things,
they will do because they
are morally responsible
individuals.
I cannot be explicit about them.
Because if I make
it explicit, then it
becomes essentially routine.
As you said, [INAUDIBLE],,
you can write it down,
this particular chocolate
came from this particular tree
and this can be eaten by only
this particular individual.
Fine.
But then how many
of them you write?
That is where essential and
necessary sufficient conditions
miserably fail, particularly
in the system when
those are coupled.
It can be fine.
Right now, if you have asked
me, the best law that we have
is Newton's laws of gravity.
What is it that
basically apple fall?
An apple was falling
before Newton.
We just did not understand this.
He was brilliant to find
out a particular law that
applies everywhere right now.
Whether I'm in Bangladesh
or in Boston, apple falls.
And I know that I can
explain it by gravity.
So that's the law
which is, I would say,
the physical law that is
replicable, verifiable,
everywhere you go.
Now to take an example
for water that I use
is that water flows usually
downhill because of the energy
gradient.
That's the physical law.
But water also flows uphill.
For example, water flows uphill
in the American west to money.
In my home on the second
floor, because I put a pump.
Otherwise, water cannot
go to my second floor.
By gravity, it should go down.
How could I get water in
my second floor bathroom?
I get it because the
water is pressurized.
So I can create conditions
that things can also
violate the physical laws.
Now when those physical laws are
violated by human intentions,
then you have a problem.
Like, for example,
Ganges was flowing fine.
India decided to
build a barrage.
Barrage was not there.
Now they can control it.
So that's a physical
control of water,
which is violating the
physical principles.
And that's when our natural
systems and human systems
are coupled, and then it
becomes a complex problem.
Is it making sense?
AUDIENCE: Yes, professor.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: All right.
So here I think I'll
give you a quiz.
And then we'll continue.
So how many colors
do you see here?
Water diplomacy-- A
Principled Pragmatic Approach
to Govern and Manage
Complex Societal Problems.
How many colors?
AUDIENCE: Three.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Three.
Good.
So remember three,
three is important here.
Then I will tell
you something else.
So water, diplomacy,
principled, pragmatic,
govern, complex, problems.
So put all kinds
of words-- and I'm
sure you have heard many of
these words many, many times
in this class.
So how many colors are here?
AUDIENCE: Seven.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Seven.
Good.
AUDIENCE: Seven.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: So you have
three and then you have seven.
So I'll just give you
one basically clue.
And then we'll discuss this
at the end of the class.
So if you really want to be
very scientific about this,
there are only three colors--
RBG, red, blue, and green.
Then, everywhere you go,
this seven color comes in.
There are seven
colors of rainbow.
There are seven heavens.
There are all kinds of
seven came into the picture.
Where did this three and
seven then came from?
I have only three color.
Why do I have seven?
Why do people say that there
are seven colors in rainbow?
In reality, if you go to
the fundamental color,
there are only three.
Now if you go to your
computer, and if you
have a 24-bit
machine, you probably
have about on the order
of eight million colors
based on this three
combination of RBG.
So I can go from three
to eight million.
And now if you just
give you a color palette
and I tell you that, fine
detail, what color is this,
there is simply no way you can
fine detail unless I tell you
what those are.
So what is my point here?
The point is that you
can take three things
and put it in
different ways and you
can get millions and
millions of combinations.
Same thing is true for this
necessary and sufficient
conditions.
I can take three variables,
or three situations
in a particular water
conflict, and arrange it
in different ways.
I can get many,
many combinations.
So in this particular
from three to seven
to millions, that is
the case, that means
my necessary and
sufficient conditions
will never be able
to be exhaustive.
I cannot do it.
Although, fundamentally,
they are related maybe
to only three.
But I cannot come
to that three level.
If I come to that three
level, it's too abstract.
So that's why I put this
basically mumbo jumbo stuff
here.
That basically you
have only 26 letters,
but you can create a
Shakespeare to water diplomacy
book and everything
else in between
by different
combinations of letters.
That is exactly the point with
this interconnected systems.
Your building blocks
may be very few.
But the way those
building blocks
are interconnected
and interdependent
may create different situations.
And that has serious
implications in the way
we think about water.
So let's go there here.
So I'll start with this
many faces of water crisis.
If you think about it,
what is water crisis?
Water crisis, if
you think about,
they'll tell you that if
you have 20 liters of water
per person per day from
an improved source,
you have access to water.
Just an estimate definition,
and that definition
is used globally.
Based on that definition, there
are about 760 million people
who does not have
access to water.
So this is what
we're trying to do--
these are our SDG.
Now if you think about this,
this is really not true.
This 760 million is not true.
Why it's not true?
There are about two billion
people lives in slums
across the globe,
from Dakar slum
to Bombay slum to Nairobi
slums, and from Brazil.
And these people are
not even counted.
Why are not they counted?
Because most of them are
in illegal government land.
So government does not
provide them water.
So they are not even counted.
They don't have access to water
or access to-- doesn't matter.
So who are these
760 million people?
These people are essentially
people in rural villages
in Africa and Asia.
So this is one problem
with access to water,
definition of water crisis.
On the other hand, when they
talk about water scarcity,
they have a
different definition.
What is this?
This is fewer than
1,000 cubic meters
of water per person per year.
So if you're in
the US, if you have
1,000 cubic meters of
water per person per year,
you are not water scarce.
So Boston, for example, is not
water scarce, but Nevada is.
But as a whole, US is not.
That translates to 2,740
liters per person per day.
Look at the difference
between 20 and 2,740--
huge difference.
Do you have access to water,
versus, are you water scarce.
These are two different things.
And we often then
get confused which
are you trying to address.
If you go to SDG, it's not
clear what they want to do.
They have that thing
is goal seven, I think,
is related to water.
And they have all
kinds of things there.
But it's so, I would say,
nebulous that it's not clear
exactly how they're
going to measure this
and how they're going
to implement this.
So access to water is not
necessarily constrained
by availability
to water, really.
It is something else.
So when you want to
talk about water crises,
and your objective is to provide
water to a slum in Bangladesh,
it's a very different
problem than saying
that I want to have
water for agriculture
production in Bangladesh.
These are two
different problems.
And oftentimes, we confuse them.
And let's go to the next one.
So what are the scientific facts
versus societal problem here?
More people die
from unsafe water
than from all forms of
violence, including war.
So these are statistical facts.
There are also
economic analysis.
Every dollar invested in
safe water and sanitation
yields anywhere between $5
to $27 in economic benefits.
You don't have to agree
with that 5 or 27--
it's more than $1.
We're not going to the
economic argument here for now.
But at least there
are many, many studies
that has done this.
That if I invest $1 right
now, I can get $5 to $27.
So that means I can
make more money.
Instead, I'm not doing it.
So what is the problem?
And then I say, OK, 768 million
people lack access to water.
Two billion people are living
in high water scarcity region.
So how come we're not
doing anything about this?
And this is the statistics I had
when I was a graduate student
many, many years ago.
How could you have
a crisis, then
you're not resolving
this crisis?
So that means it's not a crisis.
So why it's not?
Let's say that I am generous.
I want to make 50
liters, not 20--
50 per person per day.
Give me $120 billion, I can do
it for everyone in the globe.
Look at the global GDP--
$85 trillion.
Only 0.14% of global GDP.
So how come us as
a global community,
we're so much basically
benevolent, so much generous,
we cannot spend even 0.14%
of our GDP to give water
to everyone?
So the problem is not economic.
Problem is not that we
don't have the technology.
So how do I go then?
So this is where
I think maybe you
can be a little bit more
creative as water diplomats,
that these are not really
the argument that people
are making.
We need to make different
types of arguments.
So then it comes
to, basically, this
is the cover page of our book.
So we are saying
that, look, I think
when you look at this problem,
you need to look at this--
there are natural
domain problem,
there are societal
domain problem.
These have been studied
forever, but they also
happen in a
politically real world.
So in water diplomacy,
what we are arguing
for last several
years that, look,
you need to understand
the natural problem,
the societal problem.
You need to also understand
that this is happening
in a politically real world.
So how do I combine these
scientific knowledge
and social knowledge in
a politically real world
where things will have some way
to at least have some traction?
I don't have to discuss
this idea of, look,
I only need 0.14% of GDP.
Still, people do not
have access to water.
768 million people do
not have access to water.
These are all known problems.
Go to any water literature
right now, any water crisis,
you'll see these statistics
given everywhere.
So nothing is being done then.
Those are the type of
questions we want to raise.
And hopefully,
you guys will have
some clue when you are
in your organization
to have some impact.
So the reason I
think what we argue
that is happening, that
there are differences
in political boundaries,
knowledge, know-how,
management.
These are all basically
happening at multiple scales.
And these choices
are particularly
problematic because
they cross boundaries.
They have uncertainty.
They have multiplicity
of values.
So these are not
basically unknown.
What we are basically hoping
do it with our water diplomacy
framework is that we want
to explicitly recognize
this and see how to at
least adjust some of it
so that we can be a little
bit better than what
we were yesterday.
See, I may not be here
for another 30 years.
So I could not see this
changing very much in 30 years.
In 30 years, we still
had the same number
of people dying out of this
lack of sanitation and water
across the globe.
So are we basically dumb or
we are just too insensitive?
So this is where essentially
we are standing here.
And in a present,
we came from past,
but we don't know
exactly where we
came because past is--
although it came, happened
once, the interpretation
of past could be quite
different because, for example,
if you think about how I came,
where I am right now,
if you ask my mother
or my wife or my daughter,
they'll have different stories.
And some of these stories
will be probably similar,
but it cannot be
exactly the same.
So that means our
understanding of the past
is also really colored
by our own experience,
our own perspectives, and
the way we have seen it.
The problem, even,
is that future
could be even more
unknown because we have
no clue how it will happen.
But only thing we have is past.
So how do I create water
management situations
by looking at the past,
knowing that future is unknown?
So this is the
fundamental puzzle.
It's a scientific puzzle,
as well as social puzzle.
This is where you need to
basically-- the question
you are raising.
OK, in 1960, they didn't
know about climate change.
I don't know what will
happen next 50 years?
We did not know that
COVID-19 will come in 2020.
It did and it changed
the life significantly.
So those are unknown.
And then we need to have
somewhere to essentially deal
with it.
What is the next
COVID going to come?
We don't know.
So what does that tell you?
What tells you, most of our
understanding from science
is from physics.
So what physics tells us
that with classical physics,
I can essentially
describe the world
in a very interesting
and very predictable way.
But the problem
with complex system
is that they are not easily
describable by classical
physics or quantum mechanics.
World is not deterministic,
world is also not random.
It is somewhere in between.
That's what the
complex system is.
Complex systems argues
that this is not
a purely predictable system.
At the same time, it is
not a random system either.
So everything that you've
learned in school, now
is really not
becoming very useful,
because everything you learned
is essentially either based
on some classical physics, which
is deterministic equations,
or statistics.
But we're arguing that
for complex system,
neither would work.
You need a combination
of these two.
Then you come with this.
Basically, two scientists in
1973, they were telling you
"The search for scientific
basis for confronting
problems of social
policy is bound to fail."
And this is a very
classical paper
written in 1973, cited
over 10,000 times now.
DR. GAIN: Is this
"wicked" problem?
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Yeah, it
is same thing, same group.
So they were very brilliant,
two young assistant professor
from Berkeley in 1973.
So what they were
telling me, when
you are confronted
with complex problems--
we do not talk "wicked"
because "wicked,"
I don't like this word.
But they use "wicked."
But "wicked" essentially
in their term
is very similar to
what we call "complex."
And these are
interconnected problems.
These are
interdependent problems.
There is simply no way
to do cause and effect,
and particularly when there
are social policy involved.
Then came this lady
from here, Wellesley.
She was an economics
professor and chair.
She said, you can't take
politics out of this analysis.
Now you have three things.
You have physical systems,
your social system,
your political systems.
And what we argue
in water diplomacy,
we try to mix them up.
And we say that all
three are important.
And you need to be
careful about all three.
You just cannot take
one or the other.
And then your solution is not
going to be very sustainable.
DR. GAIN: So here,
how is the difference
between the social system
and the political system?
Sometimes--
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Yeah,
that is a good point.
You have to go then
to our diagram here.
Let me see if I can go back.
So I did not use "social."
I said "societal,"
so societal we
are saying that there are
only three things, because we
want to make life simpler.
We said we put governance,
assets, and norms and values
as societal.
We are keeping political
as a different entity.
So this separation
in many places
you may find to be
not really that clean.
You can put politics
also in societal domain.
That would be fine.
But then you need
to be explicit.
But here we are explicit.
We are saying that for us, when
we talk about natural systems,
we are talking about quality,
quantity, and ecosystems--
measurable, quantifiable,
more or less.
When we talk about
societal systems,
we talk about governance
and we are keeping it broad.
Governance could be your
NGO to your government
to basically your water board
in Pakistan or Bangladesh.
Norms and values could
be also quite broad.
It could be your
cultural values.
It could be religious
values of water.
So we are keeping them broad.
Assets, it's not only money.
It could be human assets too.
So we are being very careful
when we coin these terms,
we spend a lot of time
thinking about those.
So we kept them in
a way that we don't
need any more than these six.
And we have asked this
question to many of these water
diplomacy workshop
attendees that, look,
do I need anything else.
Have we missed anything?
Tell us something
that we missed?
So maybe we will ask
you the same question.
Have we missed any
variables that you
need to include to talk
about water conflicts?
Those are not there in
this particular figure.
Think of a variable or an
actor or an institution.
We are saying that
everything is included here.
Maybe think about it.
Maybe before the
end of the semester,
you can let Animesh know.
Because these are big
claims we're making.
Look, I think you
don't do anything else.
These six are good
enough, because we
have defined this
sufficiently broad
so that you can go and
dig deeper into this.
All right.
So those essentially
six now, we are
saying that we
can basically even
write it down in a little
bit more systematic way.
We're talking about variables
and processes that will
come from the natural domain.
Actors and institutions will
come from societal domain.
And then you have values,
interests, and tools.
And we go in that
particular order.
So values, so this you need
to be very, very careful.
Because what ends up
happening in most cases,
since I came from a
totally different domain--
when I was doing my
engineering stuff,
we were particularly
interested in tools.
And then we basically
started working with Larry.
And we found out that
there is something
called interests and positions.
And then we need to
talk about values.
So now we get into
really entangled mess.
Then you have problems,
policies, and politics.
What we argue that these
things have to come into place.
You have a problem, you have
policies, you have politics.
Unless these three
are aligned properly,
you're not going to get a
solution that will be basically
resilient and sustainable.
Just think about what
happened, really.
Between January 20 and
then today's April 27--
just three months.
In three months, we
have already vaccinated
about 200 million people.
That was not the case
in December/January.
What happened?
Nothing much changed in the US.
Few people change
in White House.
Other than that, most of
the actors and institutions
are the same.
So some of the problems,
policies, and politics
need to align properly.
If it does, things
can explode or things
can get totally
basically out of control.
So big-time thinking
about is basically
just the difference between
January 20 and, say, April 27.
So this multiplicity of choices,
then, what it does really,
this essentially fundamentally
challenged this idea
of finding optimal solutions.
This is what basically Rittel
and Webber found in 1973.
They were talking
about that when
you have a social problem--
we are calling them now coupled
natural human system problem.
To look for optimal
solution is impossible.
So that's the
recognition we must have,
because this is the recognition.
At least, oftentimes,
we do not have
when we are coming from
a technical domain.
From a technical domain, we
want to find an optimal solution
very quickly.
And optimal solutions
are possible
for well-structured systems.
I can find the optimal
temperature for my room.
There's no problem, because
I can put enough basically
heating and air conditioning
and thermometer to get it done.
But if I want to do optimal
temperature for city of Boston,
it cannot be done, because
city of Boston is open.
Now things are coming back
and forth from all kinds--
maybe from Connecticut or
from Maine or from Canada,
where the cold air is coming in.
So I cannot make this.
But on the other
hand, in my room,
I can do it because
the room is bounded.
So basically it has boundaries.
It can be insulated.
It can be done.
So if the system is bounded,
system is well-structured,
system is well-defined,
optimal solutions are OK.
But in most natural
systems, they are not.
In almost all coupled
systems, it's impossible.
When the natural systems and
human systems are coupled,
then you cannot find it.
Then you need to be
contingent in context.
Then you say, fine,
then what did I learn.
If everything depends on
the context and everything
is contingent, then
why come to school?
Just go and do it.
That's where I think will give
you some clue with maybe water
diplomacy and principled
pragmatism, how that can
be done, although
they're contingent,
although they're contextual.
So water diplomacy,
then, what is it?
So scientific method, I
said that, in general, it's
objective.
So we'll talk about a
little bit more closely.
So policy and decision-making
is subjective.
Whether you like it or
not, that's what it is.
So whether your political
bias is Biden versus Trump
[INAUDIBLE],, you're
seeing that policy-making
and decision-making.
So this is going
to be subjective,
whether we like it or not.
Then we are seeing the
scientific facts are objective.
Maybe, I think there are
nuances that we don't
want to get into right now.
Social facts are subjective.
So I'm making a sharp
distinction between these two
things.
So there is a scientific fact
and there is a social fact.
When we talked about this
idea of alternative facts,
where people got confused is
that they were mixing it up.
Social facts are, basically,
there are alternative facts.
Scientific fact, there
is no alternative facts.
If I take my temperature, if I
find it to be 98.4, it is 98.4.
Maybe with another
thermometer, you can get 98.5.
It cannot be 200 degrees.
So that's a scientific fact.
And I said, this is objective,
replicable, reproducible.
Social fact would be how I
feel about the temperature.
I may feel perfectly fine.
And Larry may feel perfectly
hot with the same temperature.
But the thermometer is
measuring same temperature.
How both of us feels
is quite different.
That's the social fact.
That simply cannot be
objectively defined.
And you don't have to.
But in decision-making,
both are important.
I just cannot use scientific
fact to make decisions which
will affect human beings.
I can do this for machines.
But when I bring
in human beings,
when they have emotions,
they have agencies,
they have temptations, I cannot
use just scientific facts
and assume that it will work.
As a result, now,
water diplomacy
is both subjective
and objective.
So this is essentially
very problematic
in terms of implementation.
But this is also very
good because this
is the way you'll keep your
job for the next 50 years,
because not anybody
can do it that well.
So that's the reason I think--
so Larry is doing for 50 years.
I hope I can do it too.
For another 20 years,
I'll tell you what to do.
And that is exactly
where I think
the brilliance and the
ingenuity will come in.
That this is not
easily separable.
I cannot just take objective
facts and claim that I'll be
able to do water
management very well.
Neither can I do subjectively.
So if you can combine these
two in some creative ways,
you'll have credibility and
you'll be able to do it.
AUDIENCE: Professor Shafik.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat again the example
of the temperature,
which is to illustrate
the difference between the
subjective and objective?
PROFESSOR ISLAM: OK, so
just one second here.
Let me see here.
So objective facts
would be, I would
say-- we will go this
into a little bit
more detail [INAUDIBLE].
So objective fact, I am
defining it very sharply.
So in my definition,
objective fact
is based on scientific
matters which are observable.
It has to be observable.
If it is not observable,
so observable by how.
So then basically if you
really want to be very sure,
you said we have five senses.
If these are not sensed by your
five senses, it doesn't exist.
So I'll tell you,
although I don't
want to basically make our
friend Pinker in other school
on the Red Line.
He's a cognitive
psychologist at Harvard.
So he would tell you really
everything else that you cannot
sense or can't
observe doesn't exist.
So trust-- it doesn't exist.
Trust simply is not measurable.
He has a whole book
called "Enlightenment."
700 pages with hundreds
of thousands of graphs.
And he's showing that with
enlightenment we have basically
done remarkably well.
Because in all measures
that he shows--
of course, he's very
selective in showing
that everything has improved.
Like, our infant
mortality has improved.
Our war has gone down.
People dying from
war has gone down.
People dying out of
hunger has gone down.
So we are doing well.
But in that book, trust was
not even mentioned once.
Because he doesn't care
really about trust.
So for him, it's
a scientific fact.
Unless it is observable,
it's not scientific.
Social fact now, I feel bad.
And we have too many people
suffering from mental disease
right now.
Mental disease will become
the most pandemic really
in the next 20 years, he
doesn't want to talk about this.
So funny, those are
subjective judgment.
You figure it out.
So that's the difference.
He thinks those are
not observable--
doesn't exist.
So that's a very sharp, it's
a very crude definition,
but that's the way I
try to do this also.
So I say subjective is
meaning that these are not
easily verifiable.
But I do disagree with
him that, no, they exist.
I may not be able to measure
them, but they're real.
He will say that
they're not even real.
They're just a fiction
of your imagination.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: So
that brings us to this.
I think this you will like now.
So here, I want you to
look at these two pictures.
And I thought it was very nice.
So there is a difference
between myth and fact.
Look at this first figure.
And then remember what
this individual is doing.
This individual now
remembers myths.
Although you have
given him 12 facts.
So what is the problem?
The problem is that
our cognitive ability
to process information
is not really very good.
So if you give me a
lot of information--
it's happening with COVID.
If you think about
COVID clearly,
people are so confused.
It's not that
people are confused.
People just simply
cannot separate it out,
because you are giving me
so many facts and so many
conflicting facts, so ultimately
you remember the myth that most
likely I'll die.
Although the
probability of you dying
is extremely low,
even if you get it.
On the other hand,
if you can give myth
with some carefully
constructed facts,
you do remember the fact.
So the argument
that I'll make here
is that our challenge
is to essentially,
when I'm trying to
debunk some of this myth
or some of the social facts,
to create scientific facts.
Those are easily
digestible to the audience
that I'm giving it to.
But that's very, very powerful.
Because otherwise, I can keep
talking about this climate
change.
In general, public
does not understand
what I'm talking about.
As a result, they
think it's a hoax.
So what does that
mean really is this.
When you're trying to replace
a myth from somebody's mind,
you need to replace
it by some facts.
Otherwise, it will get
replaced by another myth.
So the question is basically
and the politicians
are extremely powerful really
in basically replacing myths.
And myth are not really
easily discounted.
I don't believe that myth
can be easily taken out.
They will be there.
The challenge is to create
myth those are little
bit more scientifically valid.
If you can do this,
then I think you
have an alternative narrative.
Otherwise, you don't have
an alternative narrative.
You have no way to make any
influence in the policy-making
and the decision-making.
So that brings us to something
that I like is that--
you remember when you talk
about water diplomacy framework,
we did not say
that this is model.
It is not even a
theory right now.
So what is a framework?
Framework is
something that is it's
some general ideas and
general relationships that
gives you to address
a particular problem
in a particular way.
So that is the framework.
When the framework
get tested over time,
so we are doing it for
many, many years right now,
gradually it will
become a theory.
Eventually it will become
a model and predictable.
So right now, we'll put
on water diplomacy--
principled pragmatism
as framework.
This framework allows us
to explain those things
in certain ways.
It allows us to intervene
When it becomes a
theory, then you just
basically like evolution.
Evolution is a theory.
Newton's law is a law.
Newton's law is not a
theory, it's not a framework.
So there is a distinction
between framework, theory,
and model.
So model is at the level that
you are the Newton's law.
So things doesn't matter
really whether I'm in Boston
or I'm in Brazil.
Newton's laws applies.
So that is what
the difference is.
So if you can
develop certain law,
those are context-independent,
then you have a law.
So do I have a law for water?
No I don't.
I don't have a
water diplomacy law.
We have a water
diplomacy framework.
And that framework
with time will probably
get tested, refined, and get
into theory and hopefully
into model some day.
So what are the principles?
The principle that we
are trying to use here
in principled
pragmatic framework
is this objective
scientific method.
So we said that there is an
objective scientific method,
these five senses.
It allows me to do certain
things in certain ways.
Those will be
independent of context.
Giving out example of taking
temperature-- so a temperature
with a thermometer is
a measurable thing.
I can easily validate this.
There is no ambiguity there.
Pragmatism comes in this
subjective interpretation now.
Because the example that
I was giving that how
I feel about temperature is
a subjective interpretation.
That interpretation
should not be confused
with scientific methods.
But I need both.
I need scientific method.
I need also subjective
interpretation.
This is exactly where
water diplomacy comes in,
that we just don't need
scientific methods.
We also need subjective
interpretation
of the local values,
local context.
Then if I can combine these two,
you get principled pragmatism.
That is subjective
and objective.
The same thing that we talked
about our water diplomacy.
Then we said, OK, like,
I think, I don't know,
you have talked about this.
We look at the world in various,
I would say, the simple way.
So we said that there are
only three types of systems.
And our first job is to
identify that problem.
And that's the diagnosis
and characterization.
So with simple problems, but
this causal relationships are
well-understood--
complicated, it's
often ambiguous, but--
not easily identified, but
you can still identify this.
Then you have complex problems--
not easily identifiable, only
perceivable in retrospect.
So a good example of this would
be like flushing your toilet.
You can go and buy
basically a toilet system
from Home Depot for $100.
It would work out very nicely.
No problem.
Bringing water to your
home from Quabbin,
like about 50 miles away,
and taking the water
on the 16th floor of your room.
And you get out,
you get warm water,
that's a complicated system.
I need lots of pumps and
pipes and then chlorination
and heating and so on.
Complex problem is
the one that when
we created this
global reservoir,
we have also eliminated
four villages from Quabbin
because we wanted to
create a large reservoir.
A lot of people has
lost their homes
and they had to be bought out.
So was this right to do?
Because you are
basically removing
human beings from four towns
for 200 years, because Boston
has to grow.
Boston needed more water.
They needed to create the
Quabbin Reserve in 1920s.
So they created this by
eliminating four villages.
And there is still people
complaining that that was not
the right thing to do.
So that's a complex problem
where you have basically
coupled a natural system
with the human systems.
Now the system is, in this case,
is knowable and predictable.
So flushing a toilet is
more or less predictable.
This is complicated, but it's
still more or less predictable.
Not always, but this
one is most of the time
unpredictable and emergent.
Meaning, that things
will just emerge
that you had no idea that
it was going to come.
And from your
arsenic problem, you
have seen some of
this emergence.
We'll talk about
a little bit more.
If you are to intervene
in these systems,
this will work with
best practices.
And this is where I think most
of the people got it wrong.
And I think we want
you to be very careful.
What we are saying here is that,
your best practices will apply
very well for simple systems.
If you go into a
complicated system,
you need some
expert knowledge now
and some contextual knowledge.
If you go into complex
system, now you
need something
totally different.
You need a synthesis
of scientific facts
and social facts.
You simply cannot
use best practices.
Because there is no best
practices for complex systems.
And although you will
hear this term often,
"give me a roadmap," no, I
cannot give you a roadmap.
The roadmap assumes
that I know the road.
So how do I know the road?
I know the road because
I've seen it in the past.
So that means I'm assuming
the past will essentially be
similar in the future as well.
If the future is a little
bit different than the past,
my past knowledge is not
going to be very useful.
So I cannot have a roadmap.
So to hope for a roadmap,
to hope for a best practices
is an illusion we must abandon
to deal with complex problems.
Is it making sense?
But this is very
important because we
need to make a distinction
between these three
colossal problems.
Your first job would be
to essentially decide
which one is simple, which is
complicated, which is complex.
And then you cannot
use the tool,
those that will be
applicable for simple system,
when the problem is actually
complex, or vice versa.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
Shafik, assume
that everybody is working
on very complex problems.
Each of the cases
you heard about,
the beginning that people
describe, they're all complex.
They may have simple
components within them,
but basically the
conflicts and what's
at the heart of the
conflicts are complex.
It sounds from your
description like it's not
really possible to be usefully
prescriptive in a situation
in which the problems
you're dealing with
are highly complex.
You think that's right?
Or do we--
PROFESSOR ISLAM: No,
then we're in trouble.
At some level it is, but
at some level it is not.
So let me see what
I can explain.
So the story that what
has to happen then
is, when you are confronted
with a problem like solicited,
we are confronted with the
problem of Ganges Water Treaty.
So let's take this
as an example.
Then, we have to decide, when we
talk about Ganges Water Treaty,
what are we talking about.
So if you ask me right
now, so I'll say,
Ganges Water Treaty
should primarily
focus on the dry season flow.
So now I'm trying to make the
problem a little bit sharper.
Why dry season flow?
In the wet season, I have
about 70 to 80,000 cubic meters
per second of water flow.
That is a flood season.
Flood season lasts
for a few weeks.
But it clears the problem, but
that is a recurring phenomenon.
Then in the dry season, it's
almost about eight to nine
months.
That creates
significant problem,
both from water
availability for ecosystems
to irrigation to navigability,
so many, many things.
So I will focus on that part.
Then my question will
be, so OK, so given
that dry season flow is only
4,000 as opposed to 80,000,
now what can I do.
How do I basically resolve
this complexity of the problem?
Now we have to come up
with deal with India
and sit down and see what
adoptions can I have.
What adoption those
are possible so
that we both can come
up with some options
where we know we're not
going to get 80,000.
We need clearly actually 20,000.
We only have four.
Now how do we
solve this problem?
It's not easily resolvable.
Then, where essentially this
whole idea of mutual value
creation, negotiation, and
discussion has to come in,
rooted in scientific facts.
That's basically where I think
you can think of really how
do I get around this
mess, because otherwise it
becomes such a complex problem
that nothing can be done.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
So are you saying
that when you face
a complex problem,
try to only work on part of it?
PROFESSOR ISLAM: No.
What I would say,
that the approach
should be problem-driven.
Meaning, that you have to
define a particular problem
that you want to solve.
So here I have
defined the problem
that I want to resolve the
dry season flow in the Ganges.
That is my problem.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Right.
But isn't that really a part
of the larger problem of trying
to managing the Ganges?
PROFESSOR ISLAM: It is, it
is, no question about it.
No question about it.
And I don't think there is
any way to disentangle this.
Can you take it all separately?
No, you cannot.
So then what do you do?
So at one extreme, then
you can think of really,
everything is interconnected
with everything else.
If that is the case,
then you are in a mess.
That mess simply
cannot be untangled.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Right.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Then, you
can argue that, no, no,
you are essentially being
reductionist, because you
are trying to reduce the problem
to something that is simpler.
To some extent, yes.
But what we want to
be careful really
when I'm defining the
problem for the dry season,
I don't want it to be
a reductionist problem
that basically we do not
get affected by flood.
So I need to be careful really--
the rest of the dry
season is eight months.
These eight months will affect
the other four months too.
How?
That is the question.
If they are cleanly
separable, then it's easy.
But they are not cleanly
separable, they will not be.
So this is what the
complexity will come.
I don't think how hard we try
you will be able to go in.
That's the reason scientific
method is important,
because you need to keep this
idea of experimentation valid.
So you observe,
you ask questions,
you hypothesize your
experiment, analyze, conclude,
and keep doing this.
Then you go here.
So I think that
this I don't think
we need to call this
because this is more into--
recognize that basically
there is no panacea here.
See, if there is no
panacea, then what is there?
What I am saying that we need
to be precise in diagnosing
the problem.
So here the whole approach
that we are trying to take
is that this is a
problem-driven approach.
It is not a
theory-driven approach.
So I have a problem.
That problem is to solve
dry season water problem
in Bangladesh or in India.
Now to do this, so that is
my diagnosis of the problem.
Now what are the facets
of the diagnosis?
What aspect do I need to do?
Is it really to keep
Kolkata port navigable?
Or is it really to stop
saltwater [INAUDIBLE]
in Bangladesh?
Or both are important.
If both are important,
then how do I try to see,
given the limited amount
of water that I have,
can I do both?
If I cannot, then do
I have other options?
What if I use ground water?
Can I use groundwater in a
year and next year basically
I have more rain it gets filled.
With the groundwater, I
cannot use it forever,
because it will get depleted.
So those are the type of
discussion that has to happen.
So precisely the point
with complex system
is that complex systems
will not allow you to give
a solution that is static.
It will give you
a solution given
that particular problem, given
that time and space scale.
Then what we need to be
careful is that we monitor
and we keep adapting to
the changing situations.
So that being said, we
have to embrace complexity
with humility then.
That is not basically
I'm going to give you
a solution, that you have it.
There is no prescription
that is universal.
I cannot do it.
I'm just being very
honest and blunt.
But at the same time, I'm
giving you a framework.
That framework would allow you
to do things in certain ways.
Then you think in
a systematic way.
What does that mean?
That means that
you try to define
what your system boundary is.
What are the nodes and
links in that system?
So that when you get
this spaghetti diagram,
what are the nodes
and links that
create this spaghetti
diagram and that is
understandable and
systematically manageable?
Then you say, OK, I
diagnose and prescribe.
So I'm saying that
you need to prescribe.
So how do you prescribe then?
The way you prescribe
by understanding
the capacity of the system,
as well as the constraint
that system imposes on you.
What that means, really,
the capacity and constraints
for the Ganges between
Bangladesh and India
will be quite
different, if you are
trying to do it for the Nile
between Egypt and Ethiopia.
So the challenge here is that
you have diagnosed the problem.
Now you have to give
some prescription.
That prescription must be
consistent with the capacity
that your system has.
And that capacity can involve
basically from human capital
to basically actual
assets of money
to cultural values
and everything else.
But not all of them are
important at any given time.
The challenge for us
as a water diplomat
is to find out what those are
and try to define that subset.
Otherwise, this
set is very large.
You can go to the Ganges
and assume that, look,
Ganges water is probably one
of the most polluted water
in the world.
But it is the most holy
water for Hindus in India.
So I cannot basically start
questioning the cultural value.
That has to be
taken into account.
So that is the
capacity and constraint
the system is imposing on me.
Then I said that
there is no panacea.
So let's be clear about this,
that there is no simple,
generalizable best practices.
Then I said, OK--
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
Excuse me, Shafik.
When you say diagnose
and prescribe,
using capacity and
constraints, you
don't mean that you can't
enhance the capacity.
PROFESSOR ISLAM:
You can, you can.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: With
resources from outside
the system, right?
PROFESSOR ISLAM: No, I don't.
I think very good
point, no question.
Exactly.
I think we need to
bring in other--
capacity is not fixed.
Capacity can be enhanced,
capacity can be reinforced,
even I think can be
built, and even can
be taken as an outside energy.
So World Bank can create more--
basically can put in money.
Absolutely.
I think I need to be a little
bit more careful there.
No let's not assume that the
system capacity and constraints
are fixed.
OK.
So the question is, basically,
do we need anything else.
Because I'm also teaching
a similar class at Tufts.
So we need to pose
this question.
So I'm asking maybe
you guys also that.
OK, is this more or less
general abstract level of things
that we need to do to start
addressing the problem?
Then we'll get into very quickly
our arsenic problem, then
how this can be
applied in real-time.
I don't know-- how much
time do we have, Animesh?
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: We have
about 10 or 15 minutes.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: OK.
So, all right.
So let's do the thing.
Maybe I'll just go into this.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Could you
just go back one for a minute
to the diagram, to
the list you had?
You said, in the question marks
at the end, is that sufficient.
Is that complete?
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Do
we need anything else.
It's like one
question you raised,
I think I need to use
this [INAUDIBLE]----
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
My uneasiness
with that list is that, if
you're going to act adaptively,
if you're going to continue to
review and change what you are
doing, you need to have
the institutional capacity
to do that.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Sure.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: To build
the institutional capacity
to think and act systematically
to build the capacity,
to act adaptively.
And so the person who's talking
about taking action, I think,
needs to think about
the institutional design
for the process that
makes this list possible.
And that itself becomes
an item on the list.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Sure.
Good point.
Any other thoughts?
All right, let's
see whether we can--
so essentially that
what we are arguing--
so I hope I convinced
you-- that there
is no established
methodology exist
to resolve complex problem,
because these problems are not
deterministic nor random.
So that means you cannot use
classical physics or you cannot
use statistical
mechanics to do this.
Then, at the same
time, these problems
can neither be fully explored
by the positivist, meaning
this hypothesis testing
type of framework
that I was arguing
that with five senses.
So you cannot just use
scientific methods.
Nor can you use just
interpretations.
So it's not that basically
you can use either/or methods.
So you cannot use purely
scientific method.
You cannot use
purely subjective,
ethnographic methods to
address these problems.
What then you have
to do really is
somewhere to basically
combine your scientific facts
and social facts.
So that's what it's all about.
And if you look at the paper
that I sent you to read,
the arsenic contamination
problem essentially tries to do
this, is to explain the
problem from a scientific facts
perspective, then use
the understanding--
meaning the social facts--
to actually address the problem.
So what that means to
you is-- so let's go back
and visiting your [INAUDIBLE].
I don't go here.
So I go here.
So I use an illustrative case.
Illustrative case is that
it can support a theory.
So the arsenic
contamination problem
is used here as an
illustrative case.
Meaning that if you illustrate
that, it's a complex problem.
But it does not really provide
any validation of the theory.
But we've also used it
as an extended case.
Meaning that if I
take this case and I
look at all the features,
what I see really here is this
is a couple natural and
human system problem.
In this couple of natural
and human system problem,
when I intervene, it gives
rise to emergent properties.
And then it becomes
a complex problem.
So that means I can
use this to show really
when you have this
type of coupling,
you will expect these
type of things to happen.
So now if you take,
actually what happened then.
So basically
Bangladesh has decided
that they will promote
groundwater use as a case study
that we are using it here.
There are two policy goals.
They want to increase
agricultural productivity
and reduce infant mortality.
So these were the policy
goals they wanted to do--
very sharp, very well-defined,
easily measurable.
And then you go and
then you see this.
So this is where
essentially-- now if you
try to re-link all these
different components,
different variables, processes,
now you see this is a mess.
And this mess really is not new.
And this is not even our mess.
I think many people have
created this type of mess.
They call this system diagram,
an interaction diagram,
whatever.
And we are seeing that
this is really so old,
basically it doesn't
allow me to do anything.
I just totally get paralyzed.
So it's not going to
work, because things
are interconnected.
We understand that part.
The question then becomes,
how do you diagnose or sharply
define the problem that not
all of these links and nodes
are equally important.
Only some are.
The question is, which are.
So in the case of
dry seasonal flow,
we gave you an example relief.
That is what we want to do.
So that's a much
simpler definition
of the problem with
the interconnections
and interdependencies.
Those will be needed.
Once you have that,
then you can go here.
So if you look at what
Bangladesh has done,
they wanted to have
two policy goals.
And these were achieved really
with tremendous success.
It has increased
agricultural productivity,
decreased infant mortality.
Agricultural productivity
has gone up by almost 100%.
Infant mortality was the
lowest in South Asia.
So in those terms, it
was very good really,
very basically successful story
from 1960 to almost 1980s.
Then what you started seeing,
the arsenic contamination
emerges now.
In 1960, they did not expect
that arsenic contamination
would come.
The difficulty they
have created they
have not measured so they
are not following it.
So they were not really
monitoring the progress.
They are not being adaptive.
They did not care.
So as a result, it emerges.
Even that emergence did not
really lead to any action.
It took another 15 years.
On the day first the arsenic
was detected in water,
then to actually create
something at the government
level, it took 15 years.
Why did it take that long?
So that's where basically
the system failed.
Then you have
taken interventions
which led to even more
unintended emergence.
If you remember, really,
you looked at this.
Basically, they put
red and green wells.
Now the villages
that had red wells
now have problems with
basically girls getting married
because they have a stigma.
So you have created
a social stigma
by creating a solution
that you wanted
to do because you wanted to
let people know that there
is this well is red, meaning it
has high arsenic concentration.
So where did that come from?
What we learn from
this, this was
a theory-driven,
causality-based reasoning.
What did that come from?
So that really came from if
you know the story of cholera
in London in 1854.
And John Snow found out that--
he was an epidemiologist--
he found out that there is
a cholera outbreak in London
and they cannot find
out what is going on.
So he did a very systematic
way of finding out
who has cholera, where the
drinking water is coming from.
And he found out the well.
And he went and basically
shut that well down.
Cholera went away.
So that is basically my
theory, or by basically
scientific knowledge that
I used in Bangladesh also,
without understanding
anything else.
So I basically went and start
painting everything red,
because Snow did it
and it stopped cholera.
So if I do this,
arsenic will be stopped.
Yes, it will be.
The only difficulty there is
that this is rural Bangladesh.
Number 1, I have over 10 million
wells right now and not one.
So as a result, my theory
doesn't go with actually what
is happening on the ground.
So we got into serious mess.
And that took another
20 years to unfold.
So what would happen, in a
principled pragmatic approach,
what you want to do,
you want to find out
the problem-driven question.
So the question was that, OK,
so I have infant mortality
problem in Bangladesh.
So to solve that infant
mortality problem,
I found out the
quickest solution.
What is the quickest solution?
Dig some shallow wells.
It's cheaper, it's quicker.
Fine.
And we've done that.
And that is perfectly fine.
What was missing there is that
they did not monitor really
the progression of this.
They just assumed that
it's a simple solution.
It'll stay forever.
If they have
monitored this, they
would have found out long ago.
That's why we're seeing
this problem-driven question
with hypotheses consistent
with observed signals.
I need to keep observing
the system as it evolves.
If I can do this, then
I have an approach that
is more or less functional.
So to summarize then,
basically, what we need to do,
we need to first find out a very
sharp definition of the problem
that we want to address.
Then find out whether is
this is a simple problem,
complicated problem,
or a complex problem.
Then find out, if it is a
complex problem, then what
is the complexity coming from.
Is the complexity coming
from the scientific unknown
or is it coming from
the social fact?
Those are alternatives.
Then try to
synthesize these two.
Then design an intervention with
some basically targeted metric,
that this is what I want to do.
And then monitor
this as you go along.
Then you could be
adaptive and find
a solution that will
basically be resilient
and changes over time.
There is no universal solution.
So if have you one
message you want to take,
I think that will be that there
is no universal generalizable
solution for complex systems.
Complex systems will
bring even more problems
once you try to solve them.
By the time you
have solved them,
you have given rise to
another set of problems.
And this is also
nothing new really.
This has been done with Larry's
department for many years,
from like Sean to other people.
They have talked about these
problems almost 50 years ago,
that the idea of
when you're trying
to do these social problems, by
the time you solve the problem,
you have given rise to
another set of problems.
So the challenge
is to essentially
be very aware of that
problem nature will change.
And if it does, how do I detect
them early on so that I can be
adaptive and act accordingly?
We'll stop here.
DR. GAIN: So do you have any
final question for Shafik?
AUDIENCE: What are your thoughts
about the enabling conditions
between India and
Pakistan on taking up
the divisions in
Ganges Water Treaty?
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Enabling
conditions should be--
those will remain three.
What you want to do,
hopefully, I think,
is that what are the main
issues of contention right now.
That needs to be discussed,
because I have not
following recently
about the industry.
So what would be good
I think for if you
can identify one or two
things that both countries are
in disagreement with.
What is that really?
So I can give you one example.
For example, for Brahmaputra
is that what I followed
recently is, say,
for example, India
is claiming that China
is holding all the water
and then it will create problem.
Physically, that is not true.
Because the amount of water that
is coming from Burma for China,
even if China-- we did
this study with domination,
with another Chinese
student we had.
Even if they decide to keep
all the waters in China,
it will have no impact
in India, although they
are making that claim.
So this is essentially a social
myth they want to create,
that the Chinese are
creating problem.
But these are not
based on facts.
So what you want to do
within this, to find out
is it possible to find some very
sharp scientific facts-- those
are observable.
Like one example I
use with Bangladesh
in India for the Ganges, even
if I give all the water to India
in the dry season,
India will still not
be able to basically make
their Kolkata port navigable
during the dry season.
So that means this
is a non-starter.
Why are we start fighting this?
Try to find something else then.
Although, of course, it was
scarcest problem if India
keeps all the water
in the dry season.
But even if Bangladesh decides
I'll give you everything,
still it will not
solve the problem.
So that means you need
alternative sources now.
That part has not been explored.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
Before we finish,
I just want to
thank Shafik again.
He and I worked together
a long time on this.
And I'm always
learning something new
each time I hear him
present this material.
So thank you for taking
the time, Shafik, to meet
with the class and for
sharing your ideas.
And thank you for
having such good ideas.
DR. GAIN: Yeah, so.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: No,
thank you very much.
No, I think, No, I don't
want to embarrass Larry.
Larry has been an
inspirational mentor.
So because many of the
things that I discussed today
I did not know about maybe 15
years ago when I started out.
So we have been talking
for a long time now.
So yeah, if you
look at this guy,
you said that you need 10,000
hours to develop any expertise.
So between both
of us, we probably
spend more than
10,000 hours now.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Oh yeah.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: So
hopefully we have
some level of at least
understanding in for expertise.
DR. GAIN: But also, yeah
from our side, yeah.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Everybody
in the class, right,
the other people in this
class are potentially
the person you'll find yourself
coming back to and working
with.
Shafik and I, we did
not know each other
when we first encountered
some overlap in our interests.
And we just kept
creating opportunities
to exchange our thoughts,
and Animesh then
gets added to the mix and
now extends both of our ideas
and our work and his own work.
So everybody in the
class should imagine
that it's through
these interactions
with your colleagues that you
shape and sharpen your ideas.
So Shafik, thank you.
DR. GAIN: Yeah.
PROFESSOR ISLAM:
So for the class,
I think I have a
challenge for you.
So since you did not share
much of your thoughts,
maybe you're too shy.
So think about the arsenic
paper that you read.
I want you to find out at
least one hole, the one thing
that you found that this is
really outrageously stupid,
it's not going to work.
So I gave the same challenge
to my students also.
So there are a few things
that I have issues.
I did not share those with you.
But I will not
tell you right now.
But I want you to see really--
Larry raised something
very interesting here,
that if the institutional
mechanism is not there,
if the capacity is constant,
it's not going to work.
So we need to refine that.
But are there anything
else you see in terms
of making it operational?
See, at one point I said
the complex systems,
you don't have
generalizable solutions.
You don't have any prescription.
But then we are giving
you prescription too.
So the line is very subtle here.
But at the same time, I
don't see a way around it.
So the question is
basically how do
I bring in these
ideas of principles
of scientific methods which
are more replicable, more
reproducible with the
social effects which
are going to be continuously
subjective, continuously
contentious.
But at the same time,
decision has to be made.
So that's where basically,
where are the hiccups
or where are the binding
constant that will essentially
let it fail?
If you can think of
one or two ideas,
that would be good,
or maybe an example
that you have seen
in your real life
where you try to apply
this and see, did not work.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: He
wants you to be a white hat
hacker of his work.
PROFESSOR ISLAM:
Yup, that'd be good.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Find
programming problems.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Exactly.
So find a hole and then
that will be very nice.
That's the way ideas
gets challenged.
Otherwise, because
you will stagnate.
DR. GAIN: And also,
apart from that,
even if you have your own
specific issue regarding
water diplomacy that can
be related to the theory
that Shafik mentioned,
you can also write him
an email so that, yeah.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Sure, please.
Please feel free.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: All
right, I'm going to disappear.
But thank you so much.
PROFESSOR ISLAM: Thank
you very much, Larry.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND:
I look forward
to the presentation
starting next week.
OK.
Bye-bye.
PROFESSOR ISLAM:
All right. bye-bye.
DR. GAIN: Yeah,
thank you, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.